what's up folks I'm Walter Brennan siak
in this is top five after years and
years of anticipation and patience
Samurai Jack season five is finally
coming to Cartoon Network this weekend
so to celebrate we're going to count
down the top five best episodes of
seasons one through four what's up if
you want more Samurai Jack talks
subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome Walter because
beginning with episode 1 of season 5 on
Saturday I'll be reviewing each new
episode of the show you won't want to
miss it
debuting in 2001 Samurai Jack combined
influences from many different TV shows
and movies with the original vision of
creator genndy tartakovsky and resulted
in one of the most visually stunning and
unique cartoon shows of the 21st century
its popularity has only increased since
it went off the air in 2004 and after
years of trying to get a full-length
animated movie made Tartakovsky decided
to wrap up Jack's story in a limited
series for Adult Swim that is a lot of
people talking Jack's legacy was made in
a fantastic 52 episode original run is
worth going out of your way to see but
if you want the best of the best here
are the top five episodes of Samurai
Jack number 5 episode 18 from season 2
aka Jack and the ultra box these robots
were Jack's biggest challenge at the
time and this episode showed off some
great action and some trademark humor
Jack discovers fiery ruins of several
destroyed cities on a path that leads
him East 8th ultra BOTS are responsible
for the destruction and are unlike
anything jackets faced before their
creator xtour was forced to build them
for our COO who used his own essence to
power them now with the help of xtour
Jack has to find a way to beat these
dangerous new foes
this episode features one of the best
battle scenes in the whole series the
ultra BOTS were some pretty great
villains for this story and you get to
see Jack's fighting style enhanced by ex
stores feature tech the Robo arm used in
this episode added to an extraordinary
action sequence and made it exception
next door by the way is hilarious
high-five what high-five what
high-five I do not understand never mind
in addition to the action in humor we
are also shown just how powerful Jack
sword can be
all these elements combined for a
classic episode that is a must-see if
you re watching this show seeing Jack
with that robotic arm is just too cool
to skip out on this fight had real
station is absolutely worth seeing again
I'm Vida neighbor booth number four
episodes 45 and 46 from season four aka
The Scotsman saved Jack this is a big
two-parter filled with some awesome
thrills surrounding the mystery of
Jack's missing memories The Scotsman
runs into Jack on a ship full of bounty
hunters and finds out that Jack had
completely lost his memory and thinks
himself to be a dim-witted young man
named Brent Worthington The Scotsman
takes it upon himself to help Jack find
his memory so they begin to retrace his
steps after buying the aid of a ship and
crew the duel has led to a mysterious
area of the ocean called the great moon
what lies there is something that will
take all of the Scotsman strength to
defeat Samurai Jack is always drawn
inspiration from Star Wars but they
really put that influence front and
center in these episodes you will never
find a more wretched hive of scum and
villainy and the cupcakes are Farida
yeah but who's gonna sail it kid you
well like yeah I could I worked on a
boat before
I'm not feeling up I think most people
who watch this show have a soft spot for
the Scotsman he's a favorite character
of mine and these are my favorite
episodes of the four he appeared in yet
the greatest warrior that ever lived
beside me it does just up and go soft
and mushy on it you've mastered killers
fighting styles and weapons just it's a
visit of truth freedom I'm talking dogs
I hope he shows up I hope he shows up in
the new season in some form but what
they taking place 50 years after Jack's
first travel to the past it's probably
not likely Jack's assumed identity Brent
Worthington into a few really funny bit
look okay like I'm sure this guy is like
real cool and everything but you have
got the wrong guy
like I'm Brent okay gosh you're like
really really old
this episode is beautiful with a lot of
great design work as the Scotsman and
Jack traveled to different places
looking for clues when they get to the
source of Jack's plight and we see the
treasure room of the sirens it's another
beautifully drawn backdrop and a
magnificent setting for this episode's
climax the creepy nature of how the crew
is lured there with everyone being under
the sirens control except with Scotsman
creates an aura of mystery and fright
that the series often handled well
[Music]
[Applause]
while these episodes present a fun back
adventure for our heroes they don't
quite stick the landing the climax of
the story finishes about 13 minutes in
to the second episode which left a
considerable amount of time for filler
while that filler with Jack and The
Scotsman competing with each other to
see who will roll the boat home it's fun
it feels very strange that it goes on
for so long it's guilty of too much
repetition which the show can slip into
in its weaker moment however that
doesn't stop these episodes from
claiming the number four spot it's a
satisfying story that was very big in
scale and featured the final appearance
of a favorite character on to number
three number three episode 30 from
season three aka Jack and the zombies
Samurai Jack fights a horde of zombies
and it's even cooler than it sounds led
onto the wrong path by aku's evil hand
Jack finds himself in the middle of an
unsettling graveyard they'd get worse
when undead warriors start attacking
jack by the hundreds as aku himself
appears to do battle with this samurai
once again however this time it is a
cougar Wheeljack sword as he tries to
kill our hero with his own enchanted
blade the ending of this episode
features my favorite aku versus Jack
fight of the whole series how busy is e
to be destroyed by the blade of your
what is five it's intense it's startling
it's epic it's my favorite Mako
performance of the series as well while
we all know a2 can be really funny
sometimes
he's also pure evil and terrifying when
he wants to be that was in full force in
this episode oh wow
right
and run but you cannot hide cause I can
smell y'all back
putting aside the amazing aku Jack fight
at the end Jack's spending off of these
undead warriors had me keeping my eyes
on the screen the whole time I couldn't
look away
it got disturbing at a few points in all
the best ways Jack's abadan we all know
it but this episode shows off just how
badass he is in a way you might not
expect I love this one and you need to
check it out before season 5 stars this
next one is filled with unspeakable evil
number 2 episode 35 from season 3 aka
Jack and the haunted house the dark
spirit in this episode gives out KU a
run for his money in the evil department
Jack follows a seemingly lost little
girl trying to return her stuffed animal
his chase end at an abandoned house deep
in the woods as Jack continues his
search for the girl he encounters more
and more peculiar happenings in the dark
home what is at the center of these
disturbances is something truly
terrifying the lights of which Jack has
never dealt with this is a legitimately
scary episode the use of sound here is
so eerie
when Jack is searching the house there
are subtle little sounds thrown in there
that build the atmosphere and sense of
dread it's like a perfect suspenseful
horror movie as Jack looks throughout
the house he starts seeing flashes of
awful things these visions are animated
in a different style that works
incredibly well they're disturbing and
billed as the episode goes off
there is a scene in this episode that
I'm kind of surprised Cartoon Network
agreed to show back then Jack can't find
a way out of the house so he tries to
rest and get his wits about him however
when he wakes up he finds the girl he
was chasing sitting with her family in
an out of place pristine room he talks
with the father and begins accepting
what he sees what's in
[Music]
oh my god I don't remember seeing this
as a kid but there is a good chance I
would have loved it and been freaked out
at the same time man that was great so
then this entity consumes Jack soul
the sequence in this other dimension is
amazing.just you have to see go watch
this episode it's scary it's thrilling
and drops jack into a situation that
turned into an amazing story that
featured top-notch animation and sound
work just go watch it go go now I'll be
here when you get back I know I say this
a lot but boy it was difficult choosing
just five episodes to highlight on this
list so take these honorable mentions to
heart they're just as deserving to be
seen by fans of the show
[Music]
and the number one best Samurai Jack
episode is episode 37 and 38 from season
3 aka the birth of evil kind of strange
that what tops this list doesn't even
feature Samurai Jack almost at all in
this epic two-part tale we see the birth
of aku and how he came to fight Jack's
father for the first time covered here
are the origins of aku of evil how he
came to earth
the initial battle for Jack's homeland
and the creation of Jack's father's
sword it has been explained second hand
on a few occasions but here we are shown
in detail how aku and Jack's family came
into conflict in the most visually
stunning way possible from beginning to
end the birth of evil is a phenomenal
ride and isn't weakened at all
considering we know where the story is
going while they do change a few small
details from what we've been told before
this episode is the definitive origin
for aku showing him as this evil growth
on earth that expanded over thousands of
years is very interesting and how Jack's
father inadvertently made the form we
all know of as another layer on top of
the aku Jack rivals oh I am aku the
kögel of sorrow that deliverer of
dopplers your new master
[Applause]
this is the most cinematic the show ever
got and I could have easily seen this
being a theatrical release you can tell
how far they went to make these episodes
at the highest quality possible-- part 2
deals with the creation of Jack's
father's Shourd and that is as epic as
can be we see that it's forged from his
own pure spirit and in essence it really
is a part of him
the ending fight with aku is fantastic
we see Jack's father fight many
different versions of him and in this
final form he turns into hundreds of
soldiers that last bit is remarkable and
shows us so much of where Jack got his
strength as a warrior from
did you have jack being born at the very
end which I don't think was needed but
didn't negatively affect the second part
Samurai Jack was a show of both style
and substance that will finally get the
ending it deserves in an epic final
season over 12 years in the making
I am beyond hype hope you are too if not
you should be special thanks to the
biggest Samurai Jack fan I know my
cousin Anthony for letting me borrow the
DVD I want to hear what you guys think
what is your favorite Samurai Jack
episode what do you want me to cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
me know remember if you want more
Samurai Jack talk subscribe to my
personal channel youtube.com/ / awesome
walter i'll be reviewing each new
episode of season 5 follow me on twitter
at awesome underscore walter to take
part in more polls about what i'm a
countdown in the future come back next
week and please play a little game on a
new episode of top 5
[Music]
you